hey what's up my beautiful people
diavolo here so this video is the first
part in a three-part series
in this series we're going to be going
over every single character's names in
one piece that relates to a real
historical figure mythological deity
and famous pieces of literature as
someone who is a huge geek when it comes
to history and relatively world building
and anime it amazes me that oda has
created a world with over 1 000
characters that have their own
individual identity throughout the years
of his ever enveloping story people have
noticed some correlations between
different characters and their real-life
historical figures
like dangerous who is extremely similar
to the famous japanese thief nizumi kozo
this video and the research for has
taken me a very long time as you could
imagine with having to look into the
trivia for every single canon character
in one piece so if you do enjoy the
video and my content i'd really
appreciate if you could smash that like
button
and subscribe if you are new around here
as it really helps out with the
algorithm
also be sure to comment what you thought
the weirdest character relation was
and believe me oda has chosen some
extremely colorful characters from
history
anyway enough of that let's get into the
meat of the video so starting off we
have
abdullah abdullah's name and appearance
is based on a real-life professional
wrestler
abdullah the butcher alicia agletta
tricks was the female counterpart to the
male gladiator
there is a record of a gladiatrics named
achilla
babe babe is most likely named after the
famous baseball player babe ruth who has
been named the greatest baseball player
of all time
bartholomew kumar his surname most
likely comes from the historical pirate
bartholomew black bar roberts kumar was
revealed to have been effectively dead
during the summit war of marine ford
which concluded the golden age of
pirates and began the new age
coincidentally it was bartholomew
robert's death who entered the world's
great pirate age
also kumar may be named after
bartholomew the apostle one of the
twelve apostles of jesus this is again
another heavy coincidence
in both name and the fact that he
carried around a bible with him
everywhere he went
bartolimio shares his name with
bartolimo diaz a portuguese explorer who
was first known as the first european to
sail around the most southernmost tip of
africa
basil hawkins his name was derived from
a real-life pirate and parotia
his surname comes from basil ringrose
who was an english buccaneer navigator
and geographer while his given name
comes from john hawkins who was a
pioneering english naval commander and
administrator he was also a privateer
and an early promoter of english
involvement in the atlantic slave trade
bello betty her name might be a
reference to the real-life revolutionary
betty zayn who is believed to have saved
fort henry her appearance is based on
myrian as depicted in eugene delacroix
liberty leading the people they are both
a woman holding a flag that symbolizes a
revolution
bellamy's namesake comes from samuel
bellamy who was an english pirate who
operated in the early 18th century he is
best known as the wealthiest pirate in
recorded history and one of the faces of
the golden age of piracy
and charles bellamy an english pirate
who raided colonial american shipping in
new england and later off the coast of
canada he is often confused with the
more well-known samuel black sam bellamy
as they operated in the same areas at
the same time in the early 1700s
blenheim is also the name of several
ships of the british royal navy which
were named after the battle of blenheim
barcelina the model of kizuru's face and
japanese actor
kunai tanaka along with that kizuru's
clothes real name
barcellino and birthday are apparently
based on a movie character kunai tanaka
played in his youth the character
borcelaino from the old japanese film
tracyaro
wore a suit and sunglasses similar to
kuzaru's design kizuru's lazy and
easygoing demeanor is something of a
reference to the main character's
approach to the crime from the 1970s
french film barcellino
caesar clown he also shares his name
with real-life pirates black caesar
in which the legend says that for nearly
a decade he raided shipping from the
florida keys and later served as one of
captain blackbeard's aka
edward teachers crewmen aboard the queen
anne's revenge and henry caesar who was
a legendary 19th century
haitian revolutionary and pirate caesar
may be part based off the infamous
joseph mengele a member of a team of
doctors who conducted deadly and
inhumane experiments on prisoners of
auschwitz in nazi germany mingle created
a kindergarten and a play area for his
child
test subjects and treated them far
better than any others in the camp
providing better food and living
conditions he gave the children sweets
and referred to them kindly yet was
known for his sadistic tendencies
and complete lack of empathy towards all
test subjects
kandra and andre a fan asked if andre
and his twin brother khandre's name
were a reference to yosua inuo a
musician who debuted under the stage
name
andrei khandre and wore an afro at the
time oda affirms it as well as saying
that he knows nothing of
andrei condrey only knowing the names
from television and that there wasn't
much thought behind it
capone biggie biggie's name was taken
from two criminals his surname capone
was taken from the 1920s american
gangster alphos al capone
and his name begay from the english
privateer william lee savage
bigay also shares his birthday with al
capone
cavendish cavendish shares his name with
the navigator thomas cavendish
an english explorer and privateer
cavendish's origin as a noble and his
passion for horses may be a reference to
william cavendish first duke of
newcastle a renowned horse breeder
charlotte linlin she shares her name
with real-life pirates as well
charlotte badger a convict from new
south wales who became one of the first
pakiha women to have lived in new
zealand which is where i live so i
thought it was really amazing when i
found this out her origins and the
course of her life are difficult to
establish with certainty and charlotte
de berry who was a female pirate captain
though her story is generally considered
fictional
columbus while olympus's name is based
off the character of christopher
columbus columbus is named directly
after the famous explorer
christopher columbus was an italian
explorer and navigator who completed
four voyages across the atlantic
ocean opening the way for the widespread
european
exploration and colonization of the
americas
cassette in epony shares her name with
the character cosset from the french
novel
les miserables crossier or jose is
french for little thing she shares this
connection with a fellow german kingdom
servant a pony
crocodile though no direct inspirations
have been confirmed by a jarrah oda
crocodile's appearance and methodology
strongly invoke an iconic villain of
western pop culture
peter pan's captain hook the archetypal
hook-handed pirate who was strongly
associated with crocodiles though in
hostility rather than fondness
demarro black the fake luffy might have
been based on ferdinand wildo de maro
famous for being able to impersonate
many workers unsuspiciously to the point
of posing as a surgeon in a navy ship
and just by speed reading a textbook
prefirmed surgeries with flawless
success dengiro
ushimiti kozo is very likely based off
nuzumi kozo
a japanese thief after he was executed
he was made into a folk hero who stole
from the rich and gave to the poor like
the english legendary bandit robin hood
mizumi kozo is a nickname meaning rat
boy
just like ushimitsu kozo means watching
our boy
devil diaz his name comes from various
portuguese explorers dynastias
who was ironically a slave trader and
bartolomeo
diaz the first person to round the cape
of good hope this reference is further
supported by the fact that he was
introduced into the story at sabodi
archipelago which is the place all
pirates have to go through to get to the
new world and a slave trading haven
don quixote doflamango his surname is a
reference to
don quixote the main character of the
famous spanish novel that i have no idea
how to say so i'm putting it on screen
while his given name flamingo is a bird
whose plumage resembles doflamingo's
flamboyant jacket and likely comprises
it
don quixote was a noble committed to a
traditional knight errant in the
post-chivalry area
resulting in arguably a tragic slash
comedic consequences at the expense of
those around him
around the french revolution the text
was popularly interpreted as morality
tale of the individuals being correct
over society being wrong
edward newgate whitebeard he is one of
the characters whose name
comes from the real life blackbeard
otherwise known as edward teach
the others being marshall d teach and
thatch he shares his name with the
newgate prison which was a notorious
prison in london
active during the golden age of piracy
and where many infamous pirates and
other criminals were incarcerated
including
william kidd and members of the king of
the pirates henry evarie's crew
eustis kid kid's surname and name was
taken from two real-life pirates the
surname eustis was taken from the 13th
century french pyre and mercenary
useless the monk who was born eustis
basquiat he was a mercenary and a pirate
that operated in medieval ages as an
outlaw and the name kid from the 17th
century scottish pirate and privateer
william kidd who was also nicknamed
captain kidd he was a scottish sailor
who was tried and executed
for piracy after returning from his
voyage into the indian ocean
frankie or his real name cuddy flam is a
possible reference to the sailing ships
kadi sark and flam
kadisak is one of the last t-clippers to
be built and one of the fastest coming
at the end
of a long period of design development
which halted as sailing ships gave way
to steam propulsion
and fram as a ship that was used in
expeditions of the arctic
and antarctic regions by various
norwegian explorers
fujin shares his name with the japanese
god of wind
fujin and the puffy sash floating around
his shoulders resembles the literal bag
of wind
said god carries around fukuro kujo is
the name of one of the seven lucky gods
in japanese mythology asides from his
sunglasses
he also bears a similar appearance to
the god especially in his elongated head
gabaru his name and appearance might be
inspired by shay guevara
kiko moria it is also possible that the
main character's name
is a reference to the novel the island
of dr moreau by h.g wells
in which a scientist by the name dr
moreau gets stranded on an island and
makes experiments
creating monsters by mixing the body
parts of animals and men the
similarities between the plot
of the novel and the elements of
thrillabark art along with the similar
surrounding names of the masters of the
islands
seem to confirm the idea that maurya's
name is at least
in part a reference to moreau good her
name is possibly taken from garror
modernly known as good a goddess in
norse mythology and the wife of god
freya aside from being a goddess
gerd was also a jotan which are a race
of giants which correlates to gerd's
race in the series
who appearance particularly who hear
glasses jewelry and makeup bears a
resemblance to
dame edna evarage barry humphrey's alter
ego
jion this one is slightly different she
was created and named by a fan who said
that she was
an admiral but since all positions of an
admiral had been filled oda made her a
vice admiral instead oda
also designed her appearance which like
the admirals is based on a japanese
actor
in jion's case she's based on michio
koguru who was a japanese film actress
who appeared in
89 films between 1939 and 1984
the king of the pirates gold d roger
upon his death
the real-life pirate oliver liver had
tossed a cryptogram from the scaffolding
into the crowd and told them if they
could figure out his message
his treasure now valued at 160 million
pounds in today's money would be theirs
a treasure that to this day has never
been found this seems to have been part
of the inspiration for roger's legendary
death speech as roger himself had
delivered the message
to find his treasure and notably the
ponoglyphs are also a part of a grand
cryptogram leading to the end of the
grand line
another possible inspiration for roger
could be henry every in 1695 every led
what has been called the most profitable
pirate raid of all time capturing an
enormous treasure estimated to be worth
around 600 000 pounds
around four hundred million dollars in
today's currency becoming the richest
pirate in the world
and earning the epithet king of the
pirates despite being the target of a
worldwide manhunt and getting the
highest bounty in history placed on his
head which was 1 000 pounds
which is around seven hundred thousand
dollars in today's money every vanished
with his treasure in the caribbean which
was then called the new world similar to
the new world in one piece he is said to
have influenced the next generation of
pirates including blackbeard bartholomew
robert calicio jack samuel bellamy
and edward lowe among others who were
children at the time and those names are
also used for several one piece
characters
great michael he may be named after the
carrot of the royal scottish navy known
as great michael it was a great ship of
the royal scottish navy
she was the largest ship built by king
james iv of scotland as part of his
policy of building a strong scottish
navy
so for now that brings me to the end of
part one for every relation through a to
g
of characters in one piece that relate
to real historical figures
mythological deities and pieces of
literature i may have missed out one or
two because i didn't think the
correlation between the character and
the person in history
held enough resemblance but if you know
any more that i may have missed out
in between a and g feel free to let me
know down in the comment section below
and i'll think about making a part four
after the first three
of one set i've missed out from the
overall list that you guys have found
out for me
anyway if you guys are new around here
remember to head butt the life out of
that like button and if you haven't seen
the light of day
in a few days like myself be sure to
subscribe as i think it makes you
obligated or something along those lines
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you guys
all in a bit bye